- And here's what I think.
I don't necessarily think
young people are any different
than we were Gen Xers were.
- I agree with you.
- I don't think they are any different,
actually I think they're better.
(upbeat music)
- You got your perspective.
(engine roaring)
(crowd cheers)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
Hey, everybody it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, as many of you know
for quite a while now
I haven't been doing too many
interviews on the podcast
but I'm super excited
to break that pattern
for a very special interview this morning
and really just wishing
everybody tremendous health
and perseverance through
this challenging 2020
for a trillion different reasons.
And I'm really excited
because I know the feeling
of having a new book out six times, five
in the business sector,
one in the wine sector.
And I'm really
really excited to have
this wonderful guest
with us this morning.
Guy, why don't you tell everybody
a little bit about yourself
then we'll get into the book
and then we'll shoot
the shit in the macro.
But first of all, Guy
how are you, Guy Raz is
with us this morning.
- Thanks Gary.
I'm fine.
I think as you said, it's weird
because my general kind of disposition
is to be optimistic and positive.
And it's a grind to do that
in 2020, 2020 it's challenged
I think a lot of us
to get up in the morning
and to fight another day.
But in general, I'm doing fine.
I've got a great kids
and wife
and we're really lucky,
we've been okay.
So for those who don't know who I am
I'm the host of How I Built This.
It's a show I created four years ago.
I've been in broadcasting my whole career.
I started out as an intern
at NPR in the mid nineties.
- And even before that Guy,
what about,
before we even get into
the professional aspect
just since we have a little
bit of time, it we'll be fun.
Where did you grow up?
What kind of kid were you?
What (mumbles) sibling situation if any?
Give us the comic book one story.
- Chapter one.
Yeah.
I grew up in the San Fernando Valley
in Los Angeles, actually.
I have two older sisters
and a younger brother.
My dad...
- You're number three or four?
- Number three, four.
My dad was an engineer
and my mom was a teacher.
And at the age of 41
my dad decided to start his own business.
So he started a Pearl store.
He still sold pearls with my mom
that was my first sort of
taste of entrepreneurship.
- How old were you when he was 41?
- I was, I think I was
maybe six, seven years old.
- Okay.
- Yeah
- So you really kind of at some level
mainly remember him as an entrepreneur.
- I do.
And I remember him cold calling people
and going door to door in
downtown LA, trying to sell pearls
at the age of 41, with
three kids at the time.
- Do you have any sense of
what got him going on pearls?
- When we lived in Japan,
my dad was an engineer
he worked for a freight
company called Flying Tigers
which was then purchased by FedEx.
And while he was in Japan
he met a guy there who was like,
"Hey, you should go to LA,
"I've got a Pearl company
here and you should,
"I can be your supplier
"and you should start
a Pearl store there."
So that's really how it happened.
He had no background in pearls.
He didn't really,
he spent years learning about them
and became an expert actually.
He's retired today and became a gemologist
but that was his beginning.
He started this little
Pearl store in downtown LA
and that's how he sustained his family
for the rest of his life.
- Was entrepreneurship, something that was
in the family from either your mother
or dad's side grandparents,
great grandparents for you?
- Yeah.
I think a lot of people
with my background,
my family comes from Eastern Europe
and many of them ended up
not surviving the Holocaust.
The ones who did survive
kind of had to be reborn.
I mean, they were, they
grew up at a time where,
they were, my grandmother was a nurse.
My grandfather was a plumber.
That was...
- Did they, were they
born in the old country?
I don't know if you know this,
but I was born in the Soviet Union.
- Yeah, I know.
I know.
- So I always resonate with these stories
but I always tell my
friends and contemporaries,
I'm far more like your grandfather
than I am like you because I came
over on the boat in the
seventies, which was rare.
But a lot of these families
came over in twenties,
thirties, forties.
- My grandfather was a,
he grew up in Ukraine
and he was basically
he was sent to prison by
the communists, by Soviets,
because when he was a student, he was
it was the book by
Theodor Herzl, was found,
which was called the the Jewish State
was found in his room.
My grandfather was not as Zionist.
He didn't really know much about it.
He wasn't interested in
it, but he was set up.
So he went to Siberia
for three years actually to a prison camp.
And when he got out, he left.
- Got it.
- And that was sort of the beginning of...
- And that was your dad's dad.
- That was my mom's dad.
- Your mom, dad, excuse me.
And your dad's dad, your dad's family?
- Similar also from, most
Jews of European descent were
come from this area called
The Pale of Settlement,
which is sort of between the German empire
and the Russian empire.
They were forced to live there actually.
And so most Jews of European descent
can trace their lineage to the people...
- In that area.
- And many of them were extremely poor.
I mean, they lived in...
- Shtetls.
- Shtetls and the original ghettos
and so they weren't,
educated cultured people.
I mean, they were working...
- Grinders.
- Grinders, yes.
- For that reason the modern
second, third generation
in the US very pushed on education.
Was that a big, an oh and
then your mom's a teacher.
So are you hearing that
propaganda as a kid
get a good, go to a great
college, go to a great college.
How old are you Guy?
- I'm 45.
- Right?
So say I turned 45 in November.
So same age group like that,
someone who became kind
of a public entrepreneur
I try to tell a lot of 20 year olds.
You don't understand
this is the era where
entrepreneurship is cool.
I was actually a bad
student, a great entrepreneur
but every teacher and sprints parent
thought I was gonna be a loser.
That's how much the brand
of good college dominated the seventies
and eighties.
- And nineties.
- Yes and nineties.
- I agree.
And I think that that brand
of prestigious colleges
is really waning
and will continue to wane.
And I think about this a
lot as I save the money
in my kids, 529 plans, often wondering
what is this gonna be for?
- It's a funny conversation
Guy because in parallel
I also think you're
seeing the vulnerability
of the entrepreneurial brand
because everyone's doing it
but it's a talent.
It's like everyone deciding they're gonna
be an MBA player.
It is actually very difficult to
be a successful sustainable entrepreneur.
And I actually think the brand
of entrepreneurship has
gotten a little bit more
fratty clubby, cool, or trying to be cool.
It's actually lost a little
bit of its luster as well.
So now you've got these two
dynamics where both are going
through an interesting
transformation and it will be
interesting to see what evolves from that.
- I really think that we need to work
on redefining what it means
to be an entrepreneur.
Actually taking it back to
what it actually really means
because my grandfather
was an entrepreneur.
He was a plumber.
He employed two people, right?
My dad was an entrepreneur.
He had a jewelry store in
downtown LA selling pearls
and my mother worked with
him and he had two employees.
The person who runs the
corner grocery store
here in Oakland, where I am,
is a successful entrepreneur
actually more profitable than Uber.
- Well, it's funny when,
there's a video of me
on the internet on an
early Bloomberg TV episode
of a show that was focusing
on Tech stars very early on
in this web 2.0 bubble.
And there's eight, it's
almost like a last episode
of real world where there's
eight companies that went
through the show and Fred
Wilson and all, a lot
of people are sitting
there with me on the panel
kind of recapping the season
and every company gets up
and they kind of talk
about what's happened
since the show and eight of
the nine companies end with
and we've raised $3 million,
and the crowd goes crazy.
And then finally one
company goes up and says,
"Well we haven't raised any money.
"We've actually been able to get clients."
And Guy I'm not kidding, dead silence.
I grabbed the mic and I
go, this is what's wrong.
I'm like, we're cheering, giving
up a piece of your business
and losing money.
And we're staying silent
for people that have actually
executed entrepreneurship
- A thousand percent.
And I talk about this in my book.
I am a huge, huge
believer in bootstrapping.
And I'm a huge believer in trying to,
if you are seeking out money,
trying to seek it out from individuals
and institution, family,
foundational investors,
not venture capitalists or private equity,
because I think you're exactly right.
We think that success is
raising a lot of money.
Now look, raising a lot
of money is really hard.
It's hard to do.
You've got to convince people
that you've got a great
product and it certainly...
- Guy, would you agree with me
and I'm sorry to cut you up.
Would you agree with me
that the thing we maybe
didn't understand as
well, a half decade ago
that's becoming more obvious
is just how much money's
in the system, how much money
is actually being printed
where some of these
money, started coming from
whether it's Saudi or SoftBank and things
there is a little bit more
of an understanding that wait a minute,
and then you also have the
phenomenon of Instagram, Facebook
and others, where you had
your corner entrepreneur
that was in her, his 50, 60
seventies getting excited,
about writing a $50,000 check
into their son's best friend
because they were looking
for their lottery ticket
as the brand new startups happened.
Yes?
- Yes.
And the reality is as you point out,
I mean, there is, it's
estimated there's more
than a trillion dollars
of unspent cash sitting
in investors bank accounts
in the United States alone, right?
There is an insane amount
of money out there.
And what happens is, is when,
venture capital firms make a bet
and make a lot of money
people sort of say,
"Wow, look how brilliant they were,
"how much foresight they had."
But the reality is that,
they're putting their chips
on every single number
on that roulette table.
Every single number.
- And getting paid and
getting paid to do it.
- And getting paid to do it.
- And by the way, a percentage paid
for everybody who doesn't know, two and 20
you're getting 2% management fee
which incentivizes you
to raise as much money as
humanly possible because now
you're making listen, Guy,
this is a story I don't talk a lot about
after I invested in Facebook, Twitter
Tumbler made my name
in that web 2.0 sphere.
Before I started VaynerMedia
I had crazy money from billionaires
and family offices thinking
that I had the golden touch
and had an opportunity to make millions
of dollars a year just taking
meetings and getting 20%
of the upside and chose to start an agency
because I realized I would be
more happy being an operator
than an investor.
- I mean I think that makes a
thousand percent sense to me.
I often talk about this
and I love that you're bringing this up
because I often talk about
about what it means to be an entrepreneur.
And it's not about going out
and becoming the next LBNB
or the next Uber.
That's not what it's about.
It's about building something
that solves a problem
that you have and other people have,
and trying to make a contribution
in some way to the world.
It doesn't mean you're
gonna save the world.
It doesn't mean that your product
or brand is gonna radically transform it.
But if it improves something
about it in some way
that is more meaningful than anything
that almost anything I can think of.
And so being an entrepreneur,
building something
creating a product or service is not
it's not about scale.
It's not about billions.
It's about building something
that and allows you to
have a sustainable,
good, interesting life.
- Including things that
seem out of fashion,
which is the trickle-down
on your local economy,
aspiring your child's best
friend to do it as well
giving back to the community,
by donating a bench or a park
or even, some wine for
the local kind of PTA.
Let's go back to you a little bit here.
So you're growing up in this environment
school, school, school.
And what kind of kid are you?
Are you a bookworm kid?
Are you a sports kid?
Do you have some entrepreneurial DNA?
How did you play out that childhood?
- As a kid, like a lot
of kids, I always loved
garage sales and washing cars for money
and doing...
- So you were very entrepreneurial?
- Doing lemonade stands.
Yeah.
I mean, from the age of, my
first job at age 13 was working
at ampm Mini Market,
the Arco station around the corner
where I loved doing full service
because I'd get tips for filling
up people's cars and
washing their windows.
I mean, it was awesome.
I always worked, and this is a, by the way
this is also a different thing.
I think when we were
younger than it is now
when we were younger,
every kid I knew had a job
every teenager had a job
because that's how you made money.
Today it's different.
I think kids do a lot of activities
and are kind of over-scheduled,
and I'm not I don't
wanna say this is better
or this is worse.
- And by the way, you're
talking general trends
obviously there's a million
families listening right
now that have a 15 year old working.
- Great.
- And obviously, and by
the way, to your point
it also matters what
neighborhood you're growing up in
to your point upper-middle-class
and above scheduled
on 73 different activities,
lower middle-class and below
you've got a lot of people
working minimum wage jobs.
- That's right.
Exactly.
And as a kid, I loved that autonomy.
I loved being able to do that.
I was really into sports.
I loved playing sports.
I loved playing all sports.
I was pretty good at tennis,
but, I wouldn't say it was a bookworm.
I was a good student.
I wasn't the greatest student,
but I was pretty good
- Did you have an aspirational
college in early high school?
- Here's the thing, I didn't,
my parents emphasized education
but they weren't really
focused on prestige education.
- Got it.
They didn't care about status.
They cared about you being grounded,
but you didn't need to go somewhere
so they could put a bumper sticker
and they could be, cloud
chasing with that (mumbles).
Got it.
- Not at all.
And they weren't, it was not
that was not part of the
discourse in my house.
They would be happy if I went to
any state university in California
as a kid, I was also really,
in our family we talked
about current events.
I was really interested in politics.
I was a really passionate about politics.
And so one of the cool things
that that happened to me was
when I was 16, I actually
went to Washington DC
for the school year to
be a congressional page.
This is a program that
doesn't exist anymore.
It was stopped in the early two thousands,
but every year 60 high school juniors
would go to Washington DC
and work on the floor of the
house of representatives.
- That's incredible.
- And I got this opportunity
through my congressmen to be a page.
And that was transformational.
I, it was an amazing
experience to be there
as a kid and also to meet kids
from all over the country,
from around the country who were,
from Christian, with super
Christian backgrounds
and very conservative backgrounds.
And, I came from a house that
had sort of mixed politics.
My mom was a Republican.
My dad was a Democrat.
I was always as a kid when
I was very young, I was like
my mom, I sort of was really
into Republican politics.
When I got into high school
I was really interested in the Democrats.
And I loved...
- Well, I mean, we're the exact same age.
So it's very easy to think
about Reagan and Clinton for me.
And I was also very, very,
and I was also born in the
Soviet Union, so I'm catching
in my early years, I'm
catching cold world dynamics.
And, I also had a lot of
interests played tennis,
did garage selling.
So I didn't realize how similar we were
which is really neat.
- Brothers from another mother.
- I love it.
I love it.
So that makes sense to
me where you're going
with your, in my family,
Reagan was huge because we
had made our American dream
during that time.
He gets that credit
for me, as I got older,
Clinton was cool and progressive
and socially about the things I was about.
So it made sense.
- Yeah, exactly.
And that was sort of
my kind of life.
And I went off to college
and really I think my
plan was to do something
in public service either in
journalism or in politics.
I was always also really
interested in that.
In high school I did the student newspaper
and then in college, I did too.
So I was all, I was already kind of...
- What state did you go to college?
- In Massachusetts,
- And then what?
- And then after college,
I looked around for newspaper jobs.
I couldn't find, I couldn't get one,
because at that time, this
is now the mid nineties.
- 97 graduated or 98.
- 96.
I graduated college.
If you were an ambitious
journalist at the time
you would wanna work for a newspaper.
So trying to get a job at a place
like the Baltimore sun or
the Star Ledger in Newark
or the Boston Globe was impossible.
They took Harvard and
Princeton and Yale graduates.
I could not get a job
at any of those places.
So I actually stumbled into an internship
at NPR when I was 22 or 21, I think.
And that was, I didn't grow
up in an NPR household.
My parents had never heard of it.
They didn't know what it was.
They thought I was working
at a radio station.
I first heard it in college.
I just like tuned the dial.
And I heard the, I heard Carr Talk.
And I was like, what is this?
This is so crazy.
This is so good.
I love this.
I wanna have like a potluck
dinner with these guys.
And that's sort of,
and I discovered that they didn't actually
work at NPR in Washington,
but that's how I got into to journalism.
And that's how it happened.
- And that's kind of you got
into in that world and stayed in it.
- I got into that world
and that was sort of my career
for the next, sort of 15 years.
I started out as an intern
and at night I was writing articles
for the Washington city
paper in Washington, DC.
This was a time when alternative
weeklies really mattered.
- Big time.
- Yes.
I mean, this was like,
the editor of that paper
was a guy named David Carr
who went on to become a
legendary journalist in his own
like Jake Tapper's on CNN now as a writer
Ta-Nehisi Coates the great,
like intellectual writer was,
this amazing group of people.
So that's where I really
kind of cut my teeth
and then eventually
became a reporter for NPR.
And very early in my career
had a chance to go overseas.
So I spent almost six
and a half years overseas covering,
eventually it ended up
covering a war and conflict,
which wasn't my intention.
But, 9/11, many people
who were foreign correspondents
became war correspondence.
- That's right.
Where would you live?
- I was posted in Berlin.
I was posted in Jerusalem
and I was posted in London
but I really didn't live
in those places much.
I was usually on the
road, when I was in London
I was in Iraq all the time or Afghanistan
when I was in Jerusalem,
I was in the West Bank
or in Gaza,
or covering that conflict.
So it was a pretty amazing
incredible experience that I...
- Was you family scared
for your wellbeing?
- Yes, they were.
They were
It was a different time of my life.
I was younger.
I didn't have kids.
My now wife was my then girlfriend.
And she,
for two of those seven years overseas
I actually was a television correspondent.
I worked for CNN.
I was poached by CNN.
And then I went back to work
for NPR for a few more years.
And my wife saw me on television in Iraq,
with those night vision goggles
there were just like tracer
fire going around all over me
she was freaking out.
She's watching this from London on TV.
But that, yeah, I mean, it
was a chapter in my life
and a really important
and powerful and profound part of my life.
- How did this new show
which is now a book four years ago,
how did that start?
- Well, I became a news anchor at NPR
eventually hosted All Things
Considered on the weekend.
And then I left the news side of things
to start a new show
called the TED Radio Hour
which was a collaboration
that I did with TED Talks.
And that was just an amazing experience.
Meantime, in my head,
I always had this idea
for How I Built This and here's
where it actually came from.
So I'll go back in time for a bit.
In 2007,
I was back at NPR
and I really wanted to
be a host of a show.
I wanted to be the host of a
of an evening news show
or one of the new shows.
And at the time, the
executives in charge of
deciding who could
become a host determined
that I did not have the
qualities to be a host
that I didn't have the
personality to be an NPR host,
that I was a war correspondent
and that it wasn't
I didn't have the talent for it.
And it was crushing,
and at that time I began to think
that maybe this wasn't the
right profession for me
that I needed to find something
new to do with my life.
So I really kind of flailed
and searched around.
And I very luckily landed
on an opportunity to do a fellowship.
I applied for a fellowship.
- I apologize for a second.
- Sure.
- Did you understand
that that was literally
a subjective opinion
of a couple of human
beings and quantify that?
- No.
- No, right?
- Not at the time.
- This is why I wanted
to jump in right now
'cause I know somebody's
listening right now.
And I think you can really
help somebody right now
because I think what has absolutely worked
for me in happiness has been
when these things happen
that doesn't mean the universe took a poll
and said 80% of it was
the subjective opinion.
And by the way, a lot of
times when you're dynamic
or have some skills, you're actually scary
to the establishment, which
leads to them not seeing it.
- I think that's right.
And I appreciate that you
paused to ask about this
'cause you're right.
It is important.
It took me a long time in my life to come
to that realization.
Now in my mid forties, it's easier for me
to see it that way.
But, when I was in my
early thirties, 30, 31,
it was very hard to see it that way
a respected executive with
experience telling you
you don't have what it takes.
It means something.
And you believe that.
And I wish I could go back
and tell my 30 something,
30, 31 year old self,
"Hey it's fine.
"You got this, keep on it."
In many ways I needed that
kick in the butt though.
- Did you get rejected
from any of the colleges
that you applied to?
- I got rejected from many colleges
and I got rejected from many jobs
and over the course of my career
I wish I can talk about in depth.
- Do you feel like that was easier
'cause that was systematic
and you understood that
whereas this one was a little bit more
you thought that person really knew?
- Yeah.
And it happened a few years later.
It happened a few years later.
In 2011 my dream was to be the main host
and anchor of All Things
Considered during the week.
And I wasn't picked for that.
They decided that I wasn't
the right person for that job.
And I was crushed,
I thought this is kind
of the end of my career.
That was only in 2011.
But the thing is that
those two pivotal moments
forced me to kind of reimagine
and take, try to take
control over my career.
So in 2007, when I was told
I wasn't really capable
of being a host of a show
I looked around to figure
out how to transition.
I found this fellowship for journalists.
It was called the Neiman fellowship.
I did it for a year and that
year was transformational.
I got to spend a year at
Harvard, which is all paid for
I get to take classes at
Harvard business school.
And it was during that year actually
where I took a class
at the business school
and was blown away because
do you know the way I thought
that business school was
like charts and graphs
and abstract ideas, the way
they teach business school
is through the case study method,
I'd never heard of it before.
It's basically stories.
And I was blown away.
The first day I went to a class
we were handed this case study
about Howard Schultz and Starbucks.
And I thought, Oh my God, this
is, these are hero's journey.
These are stories that can be told.
And I kind of filed that in my mind
to kind of return to later on.
And then 2011, what happened
when I didn't get that job
I wanted, it really forced me to rethink
what I wanted to do with my career.
And at that time I began
to collaborate with TED
as the TED Talks people to start the show
TED Radio Hour and a podcast.
And by the way, at the time I was
on the radio and all my
colleagues on the radio were like
you're leaving the radio to do a what
a podcast who listens to those things.
- It was no different than
people leaving newspaper
to go to blogs.
- That's right.
- Or executives in Hollywood.
I had friends, I encouraged
friends, five, six, seven
eight years ago in Hollywood
land to go to Netflix.
And many of them did not because they
because of the perceived step back.
That we learn the lesson
that if you're thoughtful
and you can see the tea
leaves often the step back
is the three steps forward.
- That's right.
And I was nervous too.
I was like, maybe I am crazy
leaving, this is 2012, leaving radio.
- Adversity had forced
you into a framework
that allowed you to be a
little bit more comfortable
with it.
Those micro losses puts you in the mindset
and the context to make that move.
I had to, I didn't have, I had nothing.
I had no other choice really.
I didn't, there was no
horizon for me in the
using the traditional path.
So I started this podcast
and it really blew up.
We kind of rode a wave of the
kind of the podcast, Boom.
And that's really what led me into,
a completely different
phase of my career where,
I eventually started a production company
and then I started
another production company
and I made a kids' show
we we've got a kid's production company.
And then, we do How I Built This.
And so all those failures along the road
were actually meant to happen.
They were meant they were,
I'm not a believer,
I respect people who believe, but I'm not
but I do some part of me is
like, some things are just
meant to happen.
And those setbacks,
which were really hard.
I remember a lot of sleepless nights
and a lot of just feeling
really bad about myself.
- (mumbles) Meant to happen,
or do you think they,
well, there's a way to think about it.
When you just said that I'm like
they're meant to happen
to every single person
that's listening right now.
And every single person
that lives on earth
and one's perspective and
what they do with that
the serendipity of their DNA
of optimism versus pessimism
the nurturing and nurturing environment
they live in, parent
dynamics, the neighborhood,
they go into this place where,
it's amazing to me what I think about
like how romantic I am about adversity.
I would actually argue that
the biggest challenge I have
at 45 right now is do I make it harder
on myself in professional success?
'Cause I actually enjoy it so much.
The actual adversity, the
slowing down of the inevitable
the process so much.
Do you feel like they were meant to happen
or do you feel like they
inevitably happen everywhere?
And the framework one is in mentally
enables them to see the positive
or to start to dwell
and think about systematic issues
or blaming parents
like the game of dwelling
versus opportunities.
- I think that it's very
natural for humans to dwell.
I think instinctively most
of us when we're faced
with adversity at certain
points in our life,
it's natural for us to
feel really bad about it
and to try and explain it.
And I think over time
the way you explain those things
to yourself changes, right?
And so now, and really
the only way to figure
out how to confront adversity
is to experience it again
and again and again, right?
It's like any kind of muscle
you just get better at it over time.
- I'm sorry to interrupt
because I'm passionate about this.
One of my great fears was
the demonization of losing.
That parents modern parenting, again
generalizing modern parenting
has created we've demonized
losing, kids watch parents
fight coaches and parents
excuse me and teachers
on behalf of their kids
when they're faced with adversity,
we've demonized that so
much in the last chapter
still kind of now, though
there is an undercurrent
of changing it a little bit
but I do feel a lot of cliche, 20,
18 to 25 right now struggle
because they were put
in a cocoon that really demonize losing
in a world where repetition
of it really does lead
to happiness, thoughts.
- Gary, I think I have a theory about this
so I'm sure you've come across
a lot of 18 to 25 year olds
or maybe 18 to 30 year olds
who suffer from anxiety
and depression, right?
For a variety of reasons.
And the truth is, is that I did too.
When I was in my twenties,
I experienced really
debilitating depression,
something that I'd never
experienced ever before in my life.
And by the way, I was on
the fast track to a quote
unquote successful career
as a young reporter at NPR.
But I had so much anxiety
and fear about the future
and about whether I was going to make it.
And I couldn't talk
about it with my parents
because I didn't come
from that kind of culture.
When my parents talked about depression
they thought mental health
was for crazy people, right?
Which was a normal way to
think about it in the eighties
and nineties.
I don't wanna blame them
but that's how people thought about it.
And I've realized with time...
- You believe this is a stigma issue
and much like other things
we've talked about in society.
This has been a continuum.
and just thank God we're
in a place now where we can
talk about it more openly.
- And here's what I think.
I don't necessarily think
young people are any different
than we were Gen Xers were.
- I agree with you.
- I don't think they're any different.
Actually I think they're better.
I think they're more inspiring.
I think they're more, they
wanna take on the world
in a more inspiring way.
- I think they're more
inspiring and inclusive
and open and woke and all those things.
I do think that losing was demonized
for them in a way that it wasn't for us.
- I think that part may be true
but I think the fundamentals are the same,
which is think about it your whole life...
For most young people, there's a track.
You go from first grade to second grade
and then you go to middle
school and then high school.
And then if you're
lucky, you go to college
and people are cheering you on.
They're saying you got this
and you know what's coming up next.
And then a lot of people go to college
and they develop their identity there.
They might get involved in sports
or they might organize a rally
or a concert
or they're in the newspaper
and they have an identity
and then they graduate
and everyone's like,
"Yes, you got this, you got this."
And then they start life.
And the safety net's gone
they don't know what's coming next year.
Add to that.
All of this research we now
have about the human brain.
We know the human brain
continues to develop
that your executive
your prefrontal cortex continues
to develop until age 30.
So there's a slosh of
things going on in your head
at the same time, you're
starting life out.
There's no safety net
and you don't know what
you're not going to grade 13.
You're not going to the
next year of college.
So it makes a lot of sense
to me that young people,
people in their twenties are
they're so susceptible to
being anxious and depressed
because of all these things happening.
And I think really to me
the problem is we don't
talk about it enough.
We don't, and they don't
- I think there's some
real validity to that.
I really do.
Let's I don't wanna run out of time
'cause I'm enjoying too much the combo.
Let's get into the book quickly.
The show, it was an instant hit.
I admired it so much from afar.
We haven't had a chance to really connect.
So I'm glad I get to
say that to you publicly
and then the transition into a book.
And how you think about that for you
now that I have a good
sense of your context.
I'm sure it's a pretty epic moment.
- Yeah.
The show, we started it four years ago.
- Who was on the first episode?
- The first episode is Sara Blakely.
- I love it.
What a great choice.
- And it was a wonderful.
It was a wonderful episode.
and I think you get this a lot too Gary
which is for a lot of
people who watch your videos
or listen to your podcast
or who follow you on social
media, you are their MBA.
You are their free MBA, right?
And a lot of people will say that to you.
And a lot of people say that to us too.
And it's actually an amazing thing to hear
because I believe that through the stories
and the experiences and the lessons of
and the granular grind...
- Details.
- Details that you get from people
like Howard Schultz or Sara Blakely,
or Tony Shea
or any of the people we've had on the show
you learn what to do and what not to do.
- And it's funny going
back to your Harvard HBS
which is the apex of
that storytelling format.
And then the serendipity
of the people that are part of your class.
If you think about it, you're putting
out these stories in a
very dynamic, modern way.
And your quote unquote class
oftentimes are the people
that you're conversating
with on the internet about the episode
on Twitter or Instagram
or things of that nature.
- Yeah.
I'm not as good as you
are at those things.
I'm pitifully horrible at it,
but I think that's right.
And I really wanted the show
as I came to understand
that that's what the show
meant to people.
I wanted the book to do that as well.
I wanted it to be a place
that people could go to
not only to kind of have a
framework, a general framework
for how to think about starting a business
and all of the steps that it takes.
But also just if you are interested
in creating a disruptive
idea inside of your business
inside of the company, you're at.
I wanted to create a book that was full
of stories that gave people
a mental architecture
and framework for how to think creatively
and how to unleash their creativity.
'Cause I actually,
and you may disagree with this
and this may be a controversial thing
but I think there are some
entrepreneurs who are born.
I think you were born an
entrepreneur for sure.
But I do think it's that most
of the traits of entrepreneurs
are learned can be learned.
- You know, what's funny?
People always have me mistaken on this.
I view it no different than
tennis, skiing, cooking.
I can be much, much, much better at tennis
than I am right now if I put in the work.
I don't believe that I was
meant to be Novak Djokovic.
And I think you made a very
important point earlier
that I've been fighting for
in different creative ways
of communication, which
is, hey, you're not
it's unlikely that you're
going to build Spanx
or Zappos or Uber or
Facebook, or what have you.
However, isn't it remarkable
to build a business
that your family can live on
and you love doing it no different
than I am not destined to be Djoker
but nothing is more fun than
to hack around a tennis ball
with my buddies on a
weekend in the summer.
So to me, I wish entrepreneurship
I think all time entrepreneurship,
Beyonce, LeBron, Sara
Blakely, Serena Williams.
I think that's a born dynamic
with work put into it.
I think there's a lot of people, right?
I think Carol Smith
Thompson could have been
the greatest tennis player of all time.
She didn't put in the work
or even become aware that
the skill was in her.
So it goes both ways,
but I'm with you Guy.
I do think that to your point
do I believe somebody listening right now,
who's an upper middle management executive
who loves listening
who has entrepreneurial
tendencies could buy your book
get inspired 'cause
they learn in book form
more than listening to me on my podcast
and then bring a singular move
or an insight that starts a spark
within the org that moves it
a half a mile down the field.
I believe that the most,
because I'm an operator.
- I mean, I couldn't have put it better,
I think that's exactly right.
I think that...
- Let me know if you need
the forward for the next one,
I'll be ready.
- Yes, you're writing the
forward for the next book.
It's gonna say with Gary
Vaynerchuk at the bottom of that.
- But I'm glad you brought it up.
And I think it was a fair way to put...
And by the way, I've made
the mistake through my career
of speaking in sound bites,
without clarity where,
I'm sure there's videos where I'm like,
where somebody is like,
10 quick questions at the end Gary,
Entrepreneurship born or taught?
I'm like born
because I'm speaking about it
in the framework, yeah, exactly.
But I believe everybody,
look, I believe fear.
The ability to have a
relationship with fear
is 100% the trait that
talks about your ladder
of entrepreneurship.
My stomach for being wrong is so big that
I'm able to be very entrepreneurial.
Other people, making a mistake
in a meeting in a company
by reading your book
and one little petrifies them.
- Can I build on that?
- Please.
- 'Cause I think that's exactly right.
People ask, they'll say,
what is the one trait
that all the people in your show,
that you've interviewed
or in the book have in common
and people expect to hear,
Oh, they're resilient.
Oh, they're optimistic.
Oh, these kinds of things.
The reality is that they
all have the ability
to withstand rejection.
So it's
in the same side of other side
of the coin of fear, right?
Which is that if you go
to somebody and you say,
"Hey, Gary I have this great
idea, it's this product."
We're naturally,
we naturally want validation.
We want people to say,
"That's awesome go do it."
But we're really scared
of hearing people say,
"Oh, that sucks.
"Who's gonna buy that?
"That's a dumb idea."
And that is actually
what stops most people
from pursuing their ideas.
Or going to two to 10
people to raise money
or going to friends and
family to ask for support
and hearing no, no, no, no.
I'll tell you a quick
story, which is I've had
and this is very, very interesting.
I've had a fair number of
Mormon entrepreneurs on the show
David Neeleman, Joel
Clark of Kodiak Cakes,
Smith of Cotopaxi and others,
and to a person, they will all tell you
the reason why they do what they do is
because they went on a two year mission.
So if you're Mormon, you go
on a two year mission, okay.
You're sent to Brazil or wherever.
You're knocking on a thousand doors a week
trying to sell a religion to people.
And 999 of them are slamming
the door on your face.
And you've got to be polite
and gracious and keep going.
And those kids, they come back to Utah
or wherever they live at 21,
they're ready to take on the world.
- I couldn't agree more.
I couldn't agree more.
I really genuinely believe
in the same way that parents think
about sending a child to school.
More progressive parents think
about establishing nonprofit,
give back DNA.
Other parents think its travel or sport
the way many parents think we're
gonna put our kid in sport.
I genuinely believe the
notion of lemonade stand,
knock on doors and try to wash cars
getting into that place of no, no, no.
And then when they say
yes, I mean, my friend
Robbie Turner big shout
out to him is reminding me
that 70% of our childhood
first to eighth grade
because that's when we
hung out, before I moved
like 70% of the summer was washing cars,
selling lemonade, in the winter it snowed
I'm trying to rally everybody to shovel.
And so it's a no, no, no.
And then when somebody says,
yes, you have a shovel snow
for 20 minutes instead of
sledding and hot chocolate.
And that for me, and I'm the extreme
but a little bit of it, a little bit of it
I think could really help a lot of kids.
- I really do.
I completely agree.
And I think that, and look, I'm a parent.
I know you're a parent.
I'm not a perfect parent.
I'm not, I don't stand up
and say this is the model.
I screw up a lot.
There are times where I find
myself coddling my kids too,
but I really do try and
be mindful of this idea
that they need to
experience loss and failure.
And my kids played baseball
before the pandemic
and they would really lose their,
they'd lose their minds
when they'd lose the games.
And I would say,
"That's part of the game."
If you are an amazing baseball player
you're failing seven times
out of 10 at the plate.
And you're amazing, which is why...
- Hall of fame.
You're a hall of Famer.
You're failing 70% of the time,
which is why I think
baseball is a great sport
'cause it's a game of failure,
but...
- It's funny
because of the batting 300 and so hard
but this is what's great about sports
and why people love it.
Hockey missing the net,
football dropping the ball.
Basketball is, shooting percentages
are you kidding me, right?
At least 50% of the time,
and then some, and so I just,
I'm definitely passionate
about from a good place
'cause I want kids to grow up to be happy.
And I do think learning to
lose early on is a blessing.
- Yes.
And also learning to kind of take control
and have some autonomy.
That's why I agree with
you that getting kids
to build enterprises, even
if it's a lemonade stand
or a cookie stand,
which my kids do,
obviously pandemic era that makes it hard,
but that they walk away
with 20, 30, 40 bucks.
I mean, that's awesome.
- And then watching what
they do with it, right?
Do they want to buy a toy?
Do they want to save it?
Do they want to give it away?
It just gives you great insight.
I think giving kids freedom,
because again I think back
to communism and capitalism,
because I was born in one
and flourished in another,
this is a freedom capitalism, USA, USA,
meanwhile parents spend an enormous amount
of time keeping their kids in boxes.
Again I don't know how you grew up,
but we grew up in the era
where you just went outside
in the summer and that freedom mattered.
And now, it just isn't that way.
- And it's weird because,
when we were kids we would
ride our bikes everywhere.
That was my mode of transportation.
I rode all over the San Fernando Valley
on my BMX bike.
I'd go to 7-Eleven with
friends and we'd buy candy.
- Same with me BMX bike to Krauzer's,
same thing just the Jersey version.
- And now it's much safer.
America's a much safer country,
far fewer kidnappings, et cetera.
And we're so much more
protective over our children.
It doesn't make sense.
- It makes a lot of sense.
It's the
and you know this better than most people,
the news coverage
and ratings and fear and tuning,
and you and I grew up
with America's Most Wanted
being a hit show.
And, it's not super complicated.
The tone and tenor of what was
covered on the news changed.
And that scared,
a lot of people are very confused
how effective fear can be.
And I think we see that play out
in modern politics around the
world, not just in America.
And I think, it's
this is where the cocoon
your four walls as a family
really, really matters.
- There's actually a
really interesting TED Talk
by Michael Shermer about that very point.
And he argues that the
things that we fear,
we fear because they're discussed
or they're talked about actually,
we are scared of shark attacks,
(mumbles)
shark attacks are incredibly rare, right?
More people die in the bath tabs.
- Chores.
I talk about airplanes versus driving.
My mom is still scared
when I fly which is always,
and I'm like,
"Mom you should be scared when
I leave the house driving."
I'm with you.
We need to do a better job.
Talking about it in a way that
we need to find a way,
I can't believe this Guy
literally this morning,
I woke up and said,
Maybe it's this WGN thing, right?
There's this, what is it?
News Nation.
There's a new play.
You've seen this?
- Yeah.
- I've been thinking a lot about, man
I really, really, really think
because I think pendulum swing and society
I think there's a real opportunity
for a 24 hour news network
that is based on positivity,
not delusion,
but I believe in life you
find what you're looking
for and there's enormous amounts of beauty
and good going on all the time.
And I think there needs
to be a scaled outlet.
- Yeah. I mean,
if that could be the
answer, that would be great.
I'm worried that we're living
in such a desegregated time.
You think about information.
Think about this for a
minute, in the 15th century,
okay, Gutenberg comes up
with the the printed press
and all of a sudden, hallelujah.
People can get a copy of the Bible.
He can print it, he can distribute it
but it takes 400 years, 500
years for universal literacy
really to kind of grow across Europe.
So the speed and scale
at which information,
grows and develops is fairly
manageable for the human mind.
Well, over the last 20 years, we've gone
from dial up internet
to Snapchat, to Tik Tok
to social to instant,
communication and information.
That is almost impossible for
us to absorb very quickly.
And it's happened on such a
just an insane timescale that,
it's not surprising
to me that there's so much
disruption in the world.
I'll tell you a quick story.
In 2002, I was sent to
Afghanistan to cover that conflict
and NPR at the time had a
house there that we used.
It was like our, where we lived
and we had guards and
translators and drivers.
They were all Afghans.
And one night I get, go downstairs
get a cup of water.
And I can see the back house where the
the translators and the
guards are all hanging out.
And I could see a TV flickering.
Now, remember, this is a population
of people who had never
had any outside influences.
There was no satellite television.
There were no outsiders.
They hadn't seen women.
They were watching satellite television
'cause we had a satellite.
And what were they seeing
on satellite television
half naked German porn, one, 900 numbers.
Now imagine how disruptive
that moment was right
for that society.
And I'm not saying...
- You're not making judgment.
You're talking about information.
Go ahead.
- And it speaks to this idea that
we have been inundated with information
at a scale that we don't
have any precedent for.
- I couldn't agree more.
The question becomes what's
foundational in one's DNA
and upbringing in how they
decide to synthesize information
right?
I'm gonna go nonpolitical.
I'm gonna go a different direction.
I see the internet and I'm informed
in 1993, four, five, six, that
there's this internet thing.
I'm surrounded by liquor store executives.
'Cause that's liquor store executives
that was being very kind.
People that owned
or managed liquor stores in New Jersey.
'Cause that was the cocoon I
was in with my dad's world.
I see this internet thing
as the thing that is gonna
change my family's life
the 80 other people in
that cocoon that I lived in
saw it as the great
waste of time that my dad
shouldn't even let me
waste my time on that.
And they literally made fun of my dad
for letting me build the
website that would go
on to change his life.
That to me is no different
than mass information.
People look, we have deep
fake brewing at scale
it's already happening.
What that means is the thing that has
affirmed information to us for
the last hundred plus years
video will now be debated as fake always.
Which will then lead
back to the human spirit.
And that is going to be
very fascinating to watch.
- I think that's right.
And to your point about
the pendulum swinging?
I have to believe that that happens
because I think that the pendulum is swung
so far in one direction now that,
that I don't think a lot
of us like what we see.
And I think a lot of us
want to see a more honest,
equitable and fact-based world.
- The issue is right now
we're in the place of blaming
everybody but ourselves.
Right now we have enjoyed
watching people blame
Facebook as an empty pipe
and thinking that is any different.
It's amazing to watch the
surface level conversation
even by deep intellectual
individuals that don't
have any that have not gone past.
If Facebook disappears
off the face of the earth
it's laughable that people
don't understand that
humans intend to communicate
what they want to communicate.
And more importantly
humans deciding to see what
they want to see, whether that's
on Reddit or a forum or search
engines or a one-off website.
- Or Fox News
or CNN
or News Nation
or their neighbor's opinion
or during a coffee conversation.
This is the greatest era
of lack of accountability.
And we're gonna have to
go through that pain.
- Yeah.
And the question is,
how can we resolve it?
And I don't know the answer to it,
but we have to.
- Well, I can tell you one thing,
it comes far more in the sense of dialogue
than it does in cancel culture.
And right now we're in a
place where people politically
in the US,
but I want everybody who's listening
'cause it's a global audience
to understand this is
to me not a Donald Trump,
Joe Biden conversation
we're having, there is enormous
movements to nationalism
and different conversations
all over the world.
Back to the place I come
from Eastern Europe is going
through a very intriguing transformation.
My homeland the Belarus
is doing the reverse.
If they're trying to push out
their dictator of 26 years
and then there's just a
million other variables
of meanwhile
you have an entire gen Z world
that is feeling connected
to each other in a way that
we've never seen before.
You've got blonde girls in LA in love
with Korean boys that look like, in sync.
And you're leading to
just incredible dynamics.
And I think here's where
I want to go with it
which is what's the positive of this
which is the following.
If you're able to understand.
And I think everybody should get this book
because I've been following
as most of you know, I
don't consume things.
I consume people consuming things
and the sheer joy
and value that Guy's program has brought
to the table over the last four years
to the masses and to people I respect.
And just his background
and communication style has
me very hyped for this book.
So I think everybody
should go and get that.
Guy when does this come out?
- Comes out September
15th, available everywhere.
- Like you always know
Vayner Nation with me.
I always say buy it before
the date it comes out.
So go to Amazon or wherever
you want right now and get it.
But I think believe it or not
99% of the world is seeing
this 95% of the people
around you right now are
seeing this as doomsday.
And I'm moving out of the
country and we're all gonna die.
And this, I view it as
ungodly levels of opportunity
for you to bring happiness to
yourself or to your children.
'Cause think of it this way.
If a communication infrastructure has come
along in your lifetime
that is able to completely
disrupt the universe
in that there means to
be so much opportunity.
And if you choose to look half glass full
and go micro about the
things you can control
versus waiting to react to
the things that you can't
all of a sudden up pops a
Rose out of the concrete.
And I hope you can get that
from the last seven or
eight minutes instead
of where I know 98% of the mines went.
- Yeah.
I love that.
And I love that because
I think that we don't
have any other choice,
but to see it that way.
- Well, that's right.
- We have to do it, right?
What is it that gets me
out of bed in the morning
I've got two children, it's nine and 11
and I didn't bring them into the world
to leave them a world that was worse off.
We have no choice.
We have got to solve our enormous
earth scale global scale challenges from
beginning with climate change
and then everything else kind
of filters down from there.
But in the United States, we've
got huge equity challenges
in social justice and
racial injustice questions
to really grapple with.
Around the world, you talked about Belarus
and I hope they can get rid of Lukashenko
because he has been
sitting there for 30 years.
We talk about the resurgence
of nationalism in countries,
all around the world.
These, we have to hope.
- And by the way Guy you're
educated in politics obviously.
The rise of that leads to
historically very not nice things
like war at scale.
- And genocide.
- That's right.
And so to me, these,
but I want to remind everybody
because these are heavy
topics over the last,
Guy you'll love this,
over the last month, 40 of
acquaintance business associates
and friends have said the exact quote.
It's never been this bad.
And then I go into my
and I was a bad student except
I was always good at history.
And I realized later in my life
it's 'cause I love pattern recognition.
I use it for business
and it came natural to me with history.
And I said, literally
this has happened 40 times
in the last a hundred days,
Gary, it's never been this bad.
And I reply,
"You mean like the civil war?"
We are very, we have had a very good run
in the globe for the
last 30, 40, 50 years.
And I want to remind people
that it has been this bad.
There has been the depression.
There has been a civil war in America.
There's been multiple world Wars
and that's modern warfare
go back further than that.
And it gets really gnarly.
I think we need to
contextualize, I understand
that things are heavy,
but I actually have to
remind you that there are,
when you, if you were lucky enough to talk
to your grandparents
and great grandparents
they navigated very difficult
times in comparison.
- They did.
- And I think we need to
be up to the challenge.
- I agree with you.
And I think the other, to add to that
I think we have this
really privileged position
where we can learn the lessons
from those difficult moments.
There are a lot of parallels
between what's happening today
and what happened in the 1930s in Europe
a lot of parallels.
And I think if we took some
time to educate ourselves
about those parallels, we can
really figure out a way how
to navigate out of it and
how to avoid the inevitable.
Some of the inevitable things,
things that seemed
inevitable in the thirties,
which led to war and conflict
and mass destruction.
I think we are at a precipice
now in world history
where we do have the tools to
develop more empathy, right?
And we have the ability to
communicate across cultures,
across boundaries in ways that were just
unimaginable to our
parents and grandparents.
And those tools can be used
for horrible, evil things too.
But those tools can be used for incredible
positive, powerful,
powerful things as well.
And not where...
- I wish people leveled up
and realized whether you,
and I have so many
friends that see the world
on both sides of the aisle in America.
And I just remind them all the time.
I'm like, look, if you're
canceling your friends
and relatives that don't see America
the way you do that will always, always
always lead to bad for your children
because nobody's gonna
force 50% of the other side.
This only gets resolved by getting closer
to the middle for both sides.
Right now that's just not the momentum.
- It's not the momentum.
No.
- And the parallels are
incredible in business
(mumbles) to bring it back to, which is,
if you don't know how to
communicate to your customers
to your employees or to your bosses
it is always going to
lead to somebody losing
whether that's you or
them for that matter.
And so I highly recommend,
compassion, sympathy
compromise as things that work
not only in business, but in life.
- And you know what
Gary, and you know this
I have a chapter on this in my book.
I mean, the founders that we look
for on the show are kind,
we look for people who are kind.
And kindness is and it sounds hokey.
- Not to me brother.
- It's so simple.
It's so simple.
- And you know what's funny.
I have a family that's very split,
because just flat out the circumstances
of my family has family.
I have one side, not even one side
I have a lot of cousins relatives
it's very obvious to me that
kindness is very easy for me
because it is my natural DNA.
But I do believe that
people that are hurting
with their own voice with
themselves, kindness is impossible
because what ends up happening is
the misery loves company
or the dragging down
or the distribution of
the pain you feel inside
of you onto somebody else
is a coping mechanism
of how to get the poison
out of your system.
To me, kindness is not hokey.
I think kindness is the
coolest, most admirable
most important component
to business and life.
On the flip side,
though, I would challenge
and have started talking
to a lot of friends of like
I don't think kindness is
easy if you're in pain.
I think it's actually, right?
You see what I mean?
It's easy for me.
And I need to be compassionate
and empathetic that it comes easy to me
and then be aggressive to be empathetic
to those that it doesn't come
it's back to people that
say you're shitty on social.
I would feel compassion.
If you were in such a bad
place that you wanted to come
to my page and tell me, I suck.
Wow.
You must have,
I don't have the time
to go to people I admire and say,
"You're doing great."
Let alone to go to somebody
and actually spit venom.
So, wow, you're in a real
bad, kindness is hard to you
and I feel bad for you.
Let me figure out a way to create dialogue
that might create a little movement
towards a little more happiness.
- Yeah.
I love that.
I'm gonna employ that strategy next time
somebody writes you suck on my
one of my social media pages.
- Guy, it's led to the
biggest happiness for me
because you know a little bit about me
like when I hit this
will make sense to you.
I hit the social media scene early
and the early 2006 seven
Twitter was very Nirvana.
I laugh about how people view Twitter now.
It was Hippieville.
And I came in and did a
little bit of business
and everyone's like this guy.
And so I did feel a little
bit of pushback early on.
And it was through dialogue
that made me such a big part
of the web 2.0 community
because I was listening.
I was like,
"Oh, don't talk about how
Twitter can sell wine."
I see you see that as a bad thing
'cause you're going for
a much bigger thing.
I respect that.
Look, I'm trying to feed my family.
This is the perspective...
And it really helped me early on.
- Yeah.
You're so right.
Kindness is not easy.
It is a choice
and it it can be a struggle
for a lot of people.
I think that's right,
but it also it's also important
to remember that it's free.
It doesn't cost anything.
And the return on
that behavior is
I think bigger than any financial
investment you can make.
- Agree.
And it's been an unbelievable episode.
I really, I'm really
glad I said yes to this.
I've been very, very head down.
All my friends
and contemporaries that
kind of want exposure
for their projects.
I'm like come on with Tea with GaryVee
we do it for 10 or 15 minutes.
But when this email
came across intuitively
I was like, you know
what, let's get an hour.
- Thank you.
- I haven't done an interview in a while
and I'm really glad I did.
And I'm really optimistic
and hopeful for your book
and continued success with the show.
And I wish you nothing but health.
- Thank you, Gary.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- Hey, everybody on YouTube,
first of all thank you so much.
So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch,
but time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.